oui
hum hum
rassemblement pour la république un
président plébiscité jacques chirac la
police expulse les grévistes après vingt
mois d'occupation des locaux premier
congrès socialiste autorisé depuis 40
ans pour gagner il fallait jouer las le
12 et le 11 6 car demain chez tito
yougoslavie un équilibre fragile c'est
le dossier de ce journal mesdames
messieurs bonsoir c'est une actualité
bien riche que nous allons traiter très
riche points à dimanche aussi ce journal
sera t'il un peu plus longs qu'à
l'habitude
il nous fallait le temps de tout vous
expliquer en détail d'abord le sacre de
jacques chirac c'est je crois le mot qui
convient chirac superstar élu depuis
quelques heures président du rpr ou
plutôt du rassemblement car c'est ainsi
que les gaullistes néo gaulliste et
assimilés souhaite désormais se voit
rappeler et il y a bien eu cinquante
mille personnes aujourd'hui à la porte
de versailles
bienvenue une bonne centaine de
diplomates 600 journalistes 18 chaînes
de télévision 16 stations de radio pas
une fausse note dans le trio de jacques
chirac
un triomphe qui bouscule bien des
données de la politique française nous
aurons l'occasion de le voir tout à
l'heure un triomphe dont voici
l'aboutissement
le rassemblement pour la démocratie mais
aussi rassemblement dans la majorité il
ne doit y avoir aucun doute sur ce point
actée et vigilants le rassemblement pour
la république se situera résolument dans
la majorité
j'ignore
j'ignore s'il sera bientôt toute la
majorité
mézil
seniors juniors c'est le sera toute la
majorité mais il sera tout entier dans
la majorité
notre peuple dont c'est la grandeur
d'être rebelle à la contrainte a
quelquefois besoin qu'on l'exhortent
alors il se rappelle son passé et il
étonne le monde
le voici sud est réconcilié avec lui
même
réunis dans le même combat
consacrant toutes ses forces à défendre
sa culture et sa société
le voici rassemblés citoyens et
citoyennes de mon pays
vous êtes les fils et les filles de ses
hommes qui ont lutté dans notre longue
histoire pour nous donner le droit
d'être libre l'appel que je lance à mon
tour n'est que l'écho de l'éternel appel
des nations qui ne veulent pas mourir
le président chirac a parfaitement c'est
réussi son retour ou plus exactement sa
rentrée sur la scène politique dans un
nouveau décor dans ce nouveau décor du
rassemblement pour la république un
immense meeting aux accents très
gaullien grandes envolées des leaders
politiques des leaders historiques idée
généreuse et vaste public populaire et
maintenant c'est évidemment la question
que naturellement on doit se poser ce
soir d'abord l' équilibre de la majorité
va incontestablement être modifiées
jacques chirac a simplement indiqué que
son rassemblement avait sa place dans la
majorité il sous-entendait fera
certainement la première et on n'a pas
entendu présidentielle et c'est la
seconde question je crois qu'ils se
posent comment un tel mouvement va-t-il
pouvoir cohabiter avec les autres
formations de la majorité et soutenir
loyalement
le chef de l'état en suivant les yeux
fermés chirac jusqu'aux élections
l'ardeur au combat pour la victoire
atténuera sans doute les rivalités
à moins que des pétards n'éclate entre
temps comme cette affaire du parisien
libéré qui a plané sur la rassemblement
il y à des maladresses je cite qui si on
n'est pas prêts de pardonner
nous en reparlerons mais d'abord un
retour en arrière un retour sur les
premières heures de ce rassemblement
combien étaient fils 50000 peut-être
plus si effective un petit mot populaire
ce rassemblement le puissant auquel on a
parlé de grands net pour ces assises
ce fut une grand messe solennelle 58
participants électrisé et applaudissant
à tout rompre à l'évocation du gaullisme
et des thèmes qui lui sont chers
quelques sifflements beaucoup à l'égard
de la gauche du programme commun un peu
et cela a surpris lorsque olivier
guichard gaulliste ministre du
gouvernement est entré dans la salle ce
matin il guéna a rappelé que ce
rassemblement était né du départ de
jacques chirac du gouvernement parce
qu'on lui avait pas donné les moyens de
remplir sa mission
olivier guichard a mis en garde contre
ceux qui presserait pour un échec du
gouvernement barre ce serait alors
dit-il l'échec de la maison france
mais celui qui a fait le plus vibrer la
salle à part jacques chirac
ce fut ce matin michel debré qui a
montré avec toute sa fougue qu'il était
bien un chantre du gaullisme
je mènerais un certain combat avec
d'autres avec vous j'estime qu'il ne
faut pas accepter dans les circonstances
présentes dans les conditions qui nous
sont imposés l'élection de cas probables
députés à une assemblée
une raison simple et qui s'exprime en
peu de mots on ne découvrira pas notre
cher pour créer déçu présenté au dernier
bretonne leur et languedocienne
alsacienne
et nous voulons pas devenir le thé ben
heck de l'europe
voilà donc pour cette journée historique
a vécu jacques chirac jacques chirac ce
phénomène insaisissable de la vie
politique l'homme que l'on croit
toujours à contre courant et qui en fait
tu travailles sabre au clair en levant
toutes les adhésions à la hussarde
l'homme que les gaullistes sifflé en mai
74 quand il se souvenait et quand ils
soutenaient valéry giscard d'estaing et
non pas jacques chardonne à jacques
chaban delmas pardon ce mec ce même
jacques chaban delmas et tente
aujourd'hui contraints à l'abstention
l'homme qui donc deux ans plus tard kaka
à la porte de l'hôtel matignon assez
brusquement en somme un homme qui
surprend et qui n'a pas fini de sur la
vie entre la sérénité et la modération
des propos de jacques chirac est l'état
d'esprit de la plupart des militants du
nouveau rassemblement
il y à quelques nuances celui-là jure sa
fidélité à l'institution il prétend
république
mais ceci ne porte pas de giscard dans
leur coeur alors va-t-on vers deux
mouvements au sein de la majorité les
giscardiens et les chiraquiens la
question valait d'être posée à l'un des
hommes du président non ça ne m'inquiète
pas du tout d'ailleurs il y a quelques
mois il y avait 25 mille personnes pour
moi même en tant que secrétaire général
au champ de mars pour applaudir le
président de la république bien sûr donc
[ __ ] est normal qu'il ya cinquante
mille personnes
surtout si l'on veut faire un
rassemblement et joue au port en quoi
nous pûmes nous puissions nous inquiéter
tout de même jacques chirac dans son
discours n'a fait aucune référence à
monsieur giscard d'estaing ce n'est pas
un hasard
l'essentiel c'est que ce rassemblement
qui est en fait une renaissance si je
puis dire de lui les airs soit dans la
majorité
or jacques chirac a bien indiqué que le
rassemblement qu'il voulait constituer
ou qui la constituent et était dans la
majorité
je crois que c'est l'essentiel de cette
animation
maintenant pour vous il y a le
rassemblement chiraquien à droite de la
majorité vous à gauche
moi je ne peux je ne parle pas en terme
de droite ou de gauche constate
qu'effectivement les républicains
indépendants correspondent maintenant
d'après les sondages d'opinion
véritablement à un centre et récemment
dans un sondage précisément la
télévision on a classé lui d'air à
droite il réplique indépendant plus à
gauche
ça vous semble juste cela me semble
assez exacte mais ce n'est pas de notre
fait
d'ailleurs le socialiste georges sarre
se demande si la majorité n'est pas
divisée en deux clans et des pans train
de jouer les apprentis sorciers et ainsi
ouvre une période d'incertitude et
d'instabilité
voilà jacques chirac a éclipsé le reste
de l'actualité politique qui ne
manquaient pourtant pas d'intérêt par
exemple les journées européennes du cds
à strasbourg avec autour de jean
lecanuet et jacques barrot
la plupart des grands dirigeants
démocrates chrétiens de l'europe nous en
font le compte rendu dans notre dernier
journal de la soirée et puis cette
petite phrase de georges marchais à
europe 1 tout à l'heure il est à peu
près certain que lors de la prochaine
élection présidentielle
il y aura un candidat communiste donc
deuxième grand faits saillants du jour
l'évacuation des locaux du parisien
libéré ce matin peu avant 9 heures avec
comme prévu une ample réactions des
milieux syndicaux à tel point que d'ores
et déjà il est certain qu aucun journal
ne paraîtra demain et qui n'est pas
impossible que ce mouvement de
protestation s'étendre plus longuement
dans la presse d'ailleurs
indépendamment de cette action du
syndicat du livre l'union syndicale et
journaliste a elle aussi appelé à la
grève
une grève de 24 heures au nom donc au
point de départ de ce mouvement
la décision de faire évacuer ce matin
les locaux du parisien libéré occupé
depuis 20 mois par les typographes alors
que le pdg du journal et minier a mûri
décidé d'implanter ses imprimés ailleurs
dans la banlieue parisienne avec
d'autres ouvriers que ceux du syndicat
du livre
la semaine dernière la cour d'appel
confirmé l'illégalité l'occupation des
locaux
résultat ce matin l'intervention des
forces de police
8h ce matin l'imprimerie du parisien
libéré est encerclée par la police les
gardes mobiles bloquent et la rue
d'enghien et la rue des petites écuries
8h30 la chaîne qui ferme et l'entrée rue
d'enghien et découpé au chalumeau
un bulldozer enfoncent la porte et
démontent les barricades improvisées par
les ouvriers les policiers pénètrent
dans l'imprimerie sans incident 9h30
une cinquantaine d'ouvriers se barricade
dans les ateliers de la rue des petites
écuries du monde sur les toits et lance
des journaux sur la police
9h45 des groupes se forment à l'angle de
la rue saint denis les ouvriers expulsés
sont rejoints par leurs camarades
10h30 projet bureau secrétaire général
du syndicat du livre annonce arrêt de
travail immédiat dans toute la
profession
à partir de maintenant
suivant les décisions qui ont été prises
précédemment la presse écrite est arrêté
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu' il
n'y a aucun journal
à partir de maintenant qui va sortir
11 heures la police enfonce au bulldozer
la porte de la rue des petites écuries
tout le bâtiment est envahi et les
policiers arrache les drapeaux rouges
qui flottait depuis 19 mois sur les
façades tous les ouvriers sont évacués
nous à 30
plusieurs milliers de personnes bloquent
la rue saint-denis et défilent autour de
l'imprimerie 13 heures les ouvriers se
dirigent rue réaumur devant la direction
du parisien libéré une dizaine d'entre
eux occupent les bureaux et jette des
journaux sur la chaussée 14 heures la
police arrive et la cgt demande à ses
militants de se disperser 20h les rue
d'enghien et des petites écuries sont
toujours bouclé par la police
oui tout de suite après cette
intervention de la police les
interventions reste il pleuvait celle du
parti socialiste qui parlait de
véritable provocation contre l'ensemble
des travailleurs
celle d'andré bergeron qui parle d'
erreur grave celle de la peine qui va
participer à des meetings et des
manifestations demain mais qui n'osent
pas de mot d'ordre d'arrêt de travail
en face celle de la cgt de la cfdt qui
elles lanceront ce mot d'ordre là pour
demain dans toutes les entreprises
l'intervention de la police contre les
travailleurs du parisien libéré
constitue une véritable agression contre
eux et plus généralement contre les
travailleurs parce que il s'agit de quoi
sinon de la liberté de défendre son
droit au travail un droit aussi
élémentaire inscrit dans la constitution
et par conséquent la liberté de défendre
plus généralement ces revendications son
niveau de vie son pouvoir d'achat
tous les travailleurs se sentent
concernés par une pareille agression
c'est la raison pour laquelle la cgt la
cfdt ont décidé d'appeler les
travailleurs à la riposte pour la
défense des libertés pour le droit à
défendre ses revendications et c'est
pourquoi demain dans toute la france il
y aura de nombreux arrêts de travail
dans les entreprises
des rassemblements dans les localités et
à paris
bien un arrêt de travail à 15 heures
suivi d'une manifestation à ses heures
de la république à l'opéra c'est un
nouveau coup non seulement conditions de
vie des travailleurs du livre mais c'est
un coup aussi au pluralisme de
l'information la liberté de la presse
les luttes pour les deux objectifs est
tout à fait solidaire
qu'est ce que le parti communiste pense
de ces négociations tripartites proposé
par le gouvernement avec la présence
d'une personnalité compétente
il est abusif de dire que le
gouvernement qui propose la négociation
car la proposition de négociation a été
faite par les syndicats du livre depuis
le début du conflit
les parlementaires communistes
l'humanité l'ensemble du parti
communiste ont toujours soutenu cette
proposition dans la toute dernière
période avant-hier le syndicat patronal
de la presse parisienne a estimé que
cette association cette négociation et
est maintenant possible et qu'elle
pouvait aboutir positivement précisément
l'intervention policière aujourd'hui ne
facilite pas l'ouverture de négociations
mais pour ce qui nous concerne nous
estimons qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
solution qu'une solution négociée
d'ensemble pour la situation de la
presse et des travailleurs du lift
concrètement ces manifestions de demain
ça veut dire déjà deux heures de
coupures de courant demain après midi
et puis il ya cette réaction tout à fait
étonnant du nouveau rassemblement de
jacques chirac lui aussi protestent mais
pas du tout pour les mêmes raisons il
n'est pas contre le principe de cette
intervention des forces de l'ordre mais
il flaire là dessous quelques astuces du
gouvernement qui ainsi atténuerait les
faits de la journée de la porte de
versailles
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
c'est de la part de ceux qui ont pris
cette décision
une grave maladresse les parts émises de
l'intérieur par exemple et je dirais
même que c'est probablement une
manoeuvre il était tentant de faire en
sorte que les journaux ne paraissent pas
demain pour que le rassemblement son
écot et son éclat n'apparaissent pas aux
yeux des français
en fait il apparaîtra grâce à la radio
grâce à la télévision
et puis parce que vous savez les faits
sont têtus et qu'on ne peut pas aller là
contre mais je crois que c'est une
maladresse aussi parce que cela rend
furieux et gelé constater aujourd'hui
tous les journalistes de la presse
écrite
ils sont mis en quelque sorte dans
l'impossibilité de faire leur métier
c'est dommage car c'était un événement
et cela aura des conséquences au niveau
politique dans la majorité je pars je ne
veux pas exagérer cette affaire quant à
moi elle est naturellement sérieux je la
considère comme une grave maladresse
mais nous nous avons créé le
rassemblement
ça se passe quand même à un autre niveau
merci prenons donc sur ce curieux statut
des ouvriers du syndicat du livre qui
avait décidé d'occuper leur lieu de
travail
en attendant les négociations qui donc
ne touchez pas d'allocations de chômage
et qui vivait sur une caisse de
solidarité
en fait les gouvernements s'est pas
contenté de les faire évacuer
il a aussi décidé de faciliter
l'ouverture de négociations le ministre
du travail appellera demain les deux
parties à venir au ministère et si
donner une solution humaine au conflit
il y a eu une décision définitive de la
cour d'appel et il était donc normal que
la loi soit respectée
le mais vous le savez dans cette affaire
du parisien libéré le mini du travail
rempli une des tâches les plus
primordial de sa fonction qui consiste à
essayer de remplacer conciliation et
d'arbitrage
à la place de l'intransigeance
l'obstination que des patients des
conflits d'intérêts ont pu créer ce qui
fait que de maj demanderez aux
représentants du parisien libéré et du
des représentants du syndicat parisien
du livre de venir au ministère et je
leur exposerait les deux mesures
simultanées qui ont été prises d'une
part celle entraînée par le jugement
dernier ressort qui a exprimé
l'illégalité de l'occupation des lieux
et d'autre part le fait que le
gouvernement désire que ce conflit se
termine d'une façon humaine finalement
prend un risque considérable risque de
voir tous les syndicats se sont opposé
la semaine
je ne vivrai pas à croire que les
syndicats puissent penser que la loi
n'est pas la loi et ne s'impose pas nous
tous à la porte de versailles au tour de
monsieur chirac ont dit que cela est une
provocation et que la date n'a pas été
choisie par hasard alors c'est
absolument absurde vous le savez bien il
y a là une décision de justice avec
astreinte
ceci signifie que nous ne pouvions pas
tardé à prendre des dispositions pour
faire respecter la loi et aux règlements
de justice et puis dans ce mouvement de
protestation assez classique il y a un
aspect plus original c'est la prise de
position du syndicat de la magistrature
ce qui gêne les magistrats ce n'est pas
tellement à l'évacuation des locaux du
parisien évacuation parfaitement légale
c'est plutôt la rapidité de l'opération
le fait quand quelque sorte en matière
de justice
il y aurait deux poids deux mesures ce
surpris par la rapidité de l'exécution
de la décision de la cour d'appel qui
est intervenu là quelques jours il faut
savoir que lille a fallu 18 mois pour
que cette décision intervienne ce qui
prouve bien que cette affaire est
compliquée et qui plus est qu'elle est
lourd de conséquences sociales et
politiques
or soudainement le gouvernement a jugé
opportun pour des raisons qui lui
appartiennent de faire exécuter cette
décision
ce que je constate c'est que
il ya une justice à deux vitesses en
effet lorsqu'il s'agit de consacrer le
droit de propriété en expulsant les
ouvriers immédiatement en l'exécuter de
décision en revanche lorsqu'il s'agit de
défendre notre droit constitutionnel
qu'est le droit à l'emploi que le droit
de grève est bien là juste la justice ne
trouve pas de traduction pour les
ouvriers ceux ci n'ont toujours pas
obtenu satisfaction sur les différentes
instances civiles ou pénales qui l'ont
introduite à l'encontre de monsieur
moore il ya donc bien une justice à deux
vitesses voilà donc pour ce deuxième
gros dossiers de l'actualité française
il est temps maintenant je crois de
s'intéresser à ce qui s'est passé au
delà de nos frontières
à commencer par cet événement dans la
vie politique espagnole
le congrès du parti socialiste à madrid
c'est la première fois depuis 40 ans
depuis les événements de 36 la première
fois que les socialistes se réunissent
en terre espagnole à visage découvert
les incroyables
une tribune des grandes banderoles
rouges un parti de gauche qui se réunit
des poings tendus d'essayer la
boutonnière
quoi de plus naturel en europe mais ici
nous sommes en espagne ce sont en tout
cas les signes les plus concret les plus
visibles du changement car la tenue de
ce parti socialiste ouvrier ce congrès
n'aurait pas pu se tenir
il y à peine deux mois après
d'interminables tractations en coulisses
le gouvernement de juan carlos a
finalement autorisé le parti socialiste
ouvrier espagnol à se réunir
officiellement bien que ce parti ne soit
pas encore légalisé ce 27ème congrès
bien sûr prend aujourd'hui une valeur
symbolique
un an après la mort du général et
surtout dix jours avant la première
consultation libre jamais organisé en
espagne pour les militants du parti
socialiste une certaine joie de se
retrouver à la lumière et pour les
dirigeants une revanche après quarante
ans de dictature
les socialistes espagnols ont bien fait
les choses la présence de jeff brandt de
mario soares de françois héran qui n'est
pas encore arrivé de pietro ni l'italien
de l'anglais michael foot du danois en
guerre jagger scène à présent se lève
palme est la présence de tous ces
leaders socialistes européens donnent
beaucoup plus de poids aussi de
respectabilité au socialiste espagnol
pendant ces trois jours de congrès on
expliquera surtout la position des
socialistes face au prochain référendum
ils ont décidé de s'abstenir car pour
eux s'il est vrai qu'il existe
aujourd'hui en espagne façade
démocratique
rien sur le fond n'a vraiment changé ce
congrès s'ouvre dans les conditions
générales du pays c'est à dire dans une
situation pas inclure démocratique dans
laquelle un gouvernement
héritier direct du gouvernement du
dernier gouvernement franquiste est au
pouvoir
une situation dans laquelle les libertés
ne sont pas encore installés et
finalement une situation dans laquelle
les partis politiques ne sont pas encore
tous en situation de s'exprimer et
d'agir librement
premiers résultats des élections
législatives au japon monsieur tanaka
l'ancien premier ministre inculpée
emprisonné vos corruption libéré sous
caution a été réélu sans problème
les conservateurs au pouvoir depuis plus
de 30 ans semble avoir beaucoup de mal à
maintenir leur position
la participation électorale a été forte
facteur supplémentaire en faveur de
l'opposition
mais ces résultats ne concerne que le
japon rural traditionnel pour tokyo et
osaka résultats demain en fin de matinée
élection du nouveau maire de lyon ce
matin monsieur francisque collomb 66 ans
industriel père de famille et sénateur
non inscrit de tendance majorité
présidentielle a été élu à l'unanimité
moins une voix
successeur de monsieur louis pradel
monsieur collomb affirme comme son
prédécesseur ne pas vouloir faire de
politique
son objectif prioritaire la gestion de
sa ville le nouveau maire de lyon en
fonction jusqu'aux prochaines
municipales se représentera devant ses
électeurs en mars 77 déroute totale des
favoris cet après midi à auteuil le
vainqueur un outsider en havas à la
seconde place une inattendue spoleto
lutte pour la troisième place entre le
favori
le pompier et lucky brand c'est dans les
derniers mètres que s'est opérée la
décision le jockey du favori le pompier
a été pris d'un malaise à 20 mètres du
poteau il n'a pu soutenir son cheval
lucky boy en a profité pour ravir la
troisième place
le tiercé dont classe le 12 et le août
ouais
résultat de football en première
division bastia battu à nîmes 3 buts 1
laisse la place de leader du championnat
à nantes qui a réussi un match nul
contre lens 1 but partout
lyon est 2e à un point grâce à sa
victoire sur lille mais rien ne va plus
à saint-etienne de nouveau battu en
déplacement 3 busin cette fois-ci par
laval
les stéphanois qui n'ont pas gagné un
seul match hors de chez eux depuis le
début de la saison
son casier hamadi points du premier
j'imagine que demain au moment de
prendre l'avion valéry giscard d'estaing
va essayer de débarrasser son esprit des
soucis que n'aura pas manqué de créer en
lui cette actualité dimanche car il part
pour la yougoslavie pour un voyage à
l'étranger qui n'est pas une simple
formalité c'est la première fois en
effet qu'un chef d'état français se
déplace en yougoslavie et son
interlocuteur de demain et après demain
marshall tito est l'un des leaders les
plus écoutés de ce qu'on appelle les
non-alignés son pays
la yougoslavie est aussi l'un des plus
convoités par les deux blocs
tout repose sur les épaules du maréchal
tito qui a plus de 80 ans et l'on se
demande si cette unité apparente du pays
n'est pas un peu fragile belgrade
capitale de la yougoslavie depuis plus
de trente ans un chef le maréchal tito
c'est le dernier des grands dirigeants
du temps de la deuxième guerre mondiale
un dirigeant originale un communiste qui
a rompu en 1948 avec l'urss et qui
depuis n'a cessé de lui tenir tête sans
pour cela s'aligner sur l'occident un
homme qui a maintenu l'unité d'un pays
de 21 millions d'habitants répartis en
six républiques autonomes et en beaucoup
plus de minorité nationale
naguère antagonisent aujourd'hui la
yougoslavie compte six nations fédérer
la serbie 8 million et demi d'habitants
capitale belgrade la croatie 4 millions
et demi d'habitants capitale zagreb la
slovénie 1 million 800 mille capital
oublier anne à la bosnie herzégovine
trois millions sept cent mille sarajevo
monténégro 530 mille habitants capitale
titograd macédoine 1 million 600 mille
capitale skopje après ce petit cours de
géographie un peu scolaire
voyons ce que ça donne dans l'oeil n
servi une province autonome la voïvodine
la grande plaine la seule de cette
dimension ayew sa vie qui s'étend
jusqu'à la frontière de hong
stratégiquement indéfendable contre un
ennemi venu du nord à travers la hongrie
mais qui aujourd'hui pense à une défense
stratégie la voïvodine c'est le grenier
de la yougoslavie
évidemment au premier coup d'oeil il est
difficile de discerner les diverses
nationalités c'est à dire les minorités
nationales six paysans par exemple à
quelle minorité appartiennent utile en
voïvodine sur un peu plus de deux
millions d'habitants il y à un million
et demi de serbes et plus de 400000
hongrois et des dizaines de milliers de
croates de romain de slovaques de rutten
la politique du hobo slaves des
nationalités consiste d'abord respecter
les particularités culturelles à radio
novi sad
c'est en ce1 langue qu'on dit voici nos
informations of des radios novi sad d'un
modeste et h au stade des radios novi
sad transmis thème bullet in de jeter
votre avis
cette diversité coûte cher 30% de plus
que s'il n'y avait qu'une seule langue
mais finalement disent les autorités
locales c'est beaucoup plus économique
que d'avoir réprimé par la force la
police un mécontentement permanent comme
c'était le cas entre les deux guerres
passons maintenant au niveau supérieur
celui de la république des six
républiques de la fédération yougoslave
l'autonomie politique pour les affaires
qui relèvent de la république est
également un fait prenons l'exemple de
la plus petite le monténégro 530 mille
habitants sur 21 millions au total en
yougoslavie le monténégro à son
parlement et son gouvernement ce qui lui
confère une autonomie certaine dans les
affaires locales y compris financières
bien entendu le monténégro qui disposent
de ressources modestes reçoit de la
fédération une aide importante
la liberté culturelle
alors point de vue économique toutes ces
libertés locales ou régionales souligne
la diversité de la yougoslavie
une diversité une autonomie qui
logiquement pourrait être considéré
comme un risque de rupture
d'éparpillement d'éclatement du pays
flic nom historique nantes
traditionnellement linguistiquement il
s'agit des je ne dirais pas tout à fait
de même mais de très semblables peuples
qui sont venus plus ou moins au même
moment et qui ont vécu plus ou moins la
même heure et malheur dans l'histoire en
plus des aspirations historiques l'unité
qu'éprouvent les peuples yougoslave les
structures du gouvernement mis en place
par tito sont faites pour assurer
cohésion et durer ainsi la présidence de
la république et collectives et
multinationales c'est à dire que sous le
maréchal tito il ya six vice-présidents
un parent république
un serbe un croate bosniaque et cetera
le premier vice président change chaque
année par rotation cette année c'est un
monténégrins monsieur markovic mieux
encore les structures du parti
communiste yougoslave appelé ligue des
communistes sont de la même façon
collective et multinationales le premier
secrétaire du comité central et monsieur
d'hollande un slovène primus inter pares
est ce un peu plus égales que les autres
mais ce n'est pas nécessairement le
successeur de tito en vérité il n'y a
pas de dauphin la succession devrait
être collective
super stroup tournisse gré structure
mise en place par la nouvelle
constitution si monsieur ville ce
qu'offre un dessin secrétaires aux
comités centraux
ces structures ont pour but d'assurer la
continuité de la politique gaza ou à
partir du moment où le président dit oh
ne sera plus à même je remplirai
activement ses fonctions publiques
coureurs c'est la première fois un haut
responsable yougoslave reconnaît
versements dans merci à la succession du
match aller quand on est con la presse
ainsi sauf imprévu les choses devraient
se passer sans heurt l'imprévu est ce
que ça peut être malgré tout
l'antagonisme on a connu un passé entre
serbes orthodoxes et croates catholiques
plus occidentalisé les oustachis pour
actes terroristes inspirés par le
fascisme
ça existe toujours mais presque tout le
monde à nouveau choisi a tendance à les
passer de riz comme quantité négligeable
voilà il est temps maintenant de jeter
un coup d'oeil sur la météo car le
journal je voulais glee s'est prolongé
plus qu'à l'habitude une météo qui
ressemble comme une jumelle à celle
d'aujourd'hui un temps généralement gris
et froid avec le matin du verglas et du
brouillard seul le midi méditerranéen
bénéficiera malgré tout d'une certaine
fraîcheur et d'un temps plutôt clément
pour la point final à ce journal au nom
de tous ceux qui ont contribué à sa
réalisation je vous souhaite à toutes et
à tous une excellente soirée et c'était
encore quelques secondes avec nous le
rappel des titres
nouveau sigle sur la scène politique le
rpr son président jacques chirac
expulsion des grévistes du parisien
libéré pas de journaux en france jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
en espagne les socialistes en congrès
pour la première fois depuis 1936 tiercé
au palmarès las le 12 et le onze
dernières éditions du journal de la 2e à
23h05 avec didier le cas